[Music]
what's up Wolfgang Avengers infinity war
has been out for a few days now and I
myself have seen it three times in
today's video we will be going over the
ending of Avengers infinity war and
there will be some huge spoilers in this
video so if you haven't seen it yet
please click away I don't want to ruin
it for you and before we get started
don't forget to enter our giveaway for
your chance to win a full speaker system
for your home all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave give this video a like
and comment below what your favorite
superhero is Marvel DC or otherwise and
if you and your friends go to the
theater and take pictures feel free to
send them to me on my Twitter you can
tweet at me or DME personally you just
might end up in a video like these guys
ok
last chance to click off this page if
you have not seen the movie yet you
ready
so Thanos gets all the Infinity stones
and he wins throughout the movie he
successfully gathers all of the Infinity
stones and puts them in his Infinity
Gauntlet having all of the stones in the
Infinity Gauntlet gives him complete
control over all aspects of the universe
and as we learn in the movie his goal
his mission is to eliminate half of the
people in the universe we also learned
that if he has all the stones in the
Infinity Gauntlet he could snap his
fingers and make it happen and that is
exactly what he does and wiping out half
of the universe some of our beloved
Avengers go with them as well in this
list of our heroes that died we will not
count Loki Heimdall kimura or vision
because they died prior to fan of
snapping his fingers our heroes to go
our Black Panther spider-man Doctor
Strange
the Winter Soldier slash Bucky Barnes
Falcon The Scarlet Witch or Wanda
Maximoff the guardians of the galaxy
including star-lord Groot Drax and
mantis not counting rocket he survives
Nick Fury and Maria hill leaving us with
Captain America Iron Man Thor Black
Widow The Hulk / Bruce Banner war
machine rocket nebula Ikoyi and mbaku
so those are our heroes who along with
half the universe danos wiped away from
existence so what happens after Theo
snaps his fingers besides half of the
university seem to exist
Thanos get sort of transported somewhere
in which he sees baby Gamora many people
have been wondering where exactly he is
and I believe this to be sole world and
if you're wondering yes soul world is
inside the soul stone this actually sort
of lines up with the comics because in
the comics Gamora finds herself in the
soul world after being defeated by
Thanos I believe that after Thanos uses
the soul stone along with all the other
Infinity stones to wipe away half the
universe he's transported the soul world
to see the soul that he sacrificed to be
able to use the soul stone it's also
very possible that he himself chose to
go to that place using the power of the
soul stone to see Gamora the daughter
that he loved and had to sacrifice this
could very well be possible because when
he encounters her in Soul world she
asked him what it costs to eliminate
half of the universe and achieve his
plan and what she replies everything of
course he is speaking about Gamora but
let's not forget what Doctor Strange
said right before he disappeared from
existence before the fight with Dana's
Doctor Strange went forward in time and
he saw millions of scenarios where they
fought Thanos in which they only won one
of them and right before Doctor Strange
fades away from existence he tells Tony
this was the only way so strange giving
Thanos the time stone was all a part of
his plan it was all part of the scenario
in which they actually defeat Thanos
so clearly the Avengers and heroes that
remain are going to be the ones that
will somehow come up with a way to
either reverse what has happened by
getting their hands on the Infinity
Gauntlet or using time-travel otherwise
or find a different way to defeat Thanos
and it may just be a coincidence but it
is kind of funny that some of the people
that are left include all of the
original Avengers the movie ends with
Thanos finally resting we learned
throughout the movie that it has been
Thanos his sole purpose and mission
for years to save the universe by
eliminating half of its population when
he's asked in the movie what he will do
when he is done with his mission he says
that he will rest and watch the Sun Rise
and that is exactly what we see in the
final scene a very contempt Thanos
sitting on some green planet could be
earth looking at the Sun with a smile on
his face knowing that he completed his
mission and in his own eyes saved the
universe so that is it for my
explanation of the ending of Avengers
infinity war if you've seen the movie
please let me know in the comments below
your favorite part and if you haven't
seen the movie um probably shouldn't
watch this video either way it's an
amazing movie and I want to know what
you all think of it again don't forget
to join our giveaway by subscribing to
my channel subscribing to the stupendous
wave hit that like button and drop in a
comment below with your favorite
superhero Marvel DC or otherwise and
don't forget to send me pictures of you
all at the theater for a chance to end
up in a video thank you so much for
watching
wolf wolf so this is it
it's always leave English
ready let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]